good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Monday which
should be uh but it ain't and you're not
listening to last week's episode because
that's exactly how you started last
Monday happy Monday it should be and but
it ain't cause Jax is here
oh my God I guess like a pattern of mine
is being Overjoyed to see you a pattern
of yours is being consistent I'm nothing
I'm not consistent so I think that's a
good thing but no today is what's the
date I'm gonna say April 17th April 17th
the ding ding and Jackson Claude are
back together is it April 17
2021 because it feels like it with
Jackson Claude Back in the New York
Studio were we in the studio I meant
no we were in the studio in 2021 it
could be either these years they've just
flown
the days are long but the years are
short it actually has been a really long
time since we've been in New York
podcasting together not since December
Back to December all the time okay guys
Jax is back in studio it's like no time
has passed life is good nothing's
changed we're still sisters you live
here I don't live here but we could
pretend I know I'm just like I feel like
I'm cosplaying like back when I was
truly happy oh yeah
yeah that's beautiful turdy well I'm
happy to be here it's exciting to be in
New York I know and I'm excited to be
back on the toast I've really missed you
guys I really enjoyed your friends and
family week some episodes I watched
longer than others but what's so crazy
is my favorite part of the show even
when I'm doing the show but especially
as a viewer the same is the time before
the Fast Five same and as a toaster from
last week like as a former toaster right
right giving FTE
um I think we need to expand on that
segment of just like pre-fast five
nonsense chit chat I completely agree
when I go back home and like watch the
episode of the day I pretty much stop
when the Fast Five starts like I I love
to hear us catching up and I'm curious
and I think people tune in
they used to tune in for the Fast Five
now they tune in I don't know what
they're doing we will never stop doing
the faster because the Fast Five is the
reason why there's a show on days when
we have nothing to do like the fast side
keeps the show going down and I don't
want to slam it no me neither because
it's important to us and it's when we
it's the foundation in which we built
this business I just want to highlight
some of our other amazing segments and
the segment where we just do nonsense
chatter is always my favorite segment
especially like after a long weekend
with a guest host like I just really
want to hear about them I want to hear
their Dynamic with turdy yeah and that
was my favorite part then I like saw the
stories in the description I was like oh
but I also don't know if that's because
I'm like hate pop culture yeah totally
you're kind of like a hater yeah have
you been drinking a haterade no but I
think I'm just really desensitized and
Overexposed to it and sometimes the
stories are not giving but then every
once in a while Scandal there's this
story of A Century of a century and that
makes it all worth it and today every
week of watching that show yeah every
day of doing the fact you know keeping
up with these people for 10 years it
makes it all worth it and today while we
don't have like a knock down drag out
story we have really good stories
because it was Coachella over the
weekend there was a big scandivals you
don't have to dread the Fast Five today
no and then of course the the drama of
the weekend was last night's Netflix
Fiasco which we did both watch The Love
is Blind reunion we're going to talk
about it but what we're going to talk
about more is the Netflix of it all the
tech
I mean the toast would never that's all
I'll say yeah Chris Rock would never I
thought that was interesting too we'll
talk about that as well our first story
is the Netflix Saga of last night's
never-ending torture Fest that was their
attempt at a live reunion we shall
discuss and then also just like content
recap at the end yeah lots of books lots
of TV was consumed by your garlies this
weekend yes so we will share and then
I've gotten so many nice messages from
everyone because I've been out for a
couple shows with like an air of mystery
around air of mystery and I still will
explain when I'm ready I'm not ready to
talk or share yet I need a little more
time but I'm here and I'm podcast ready
so like I still want to do the show and
and I'll get to it I just it's today's
not the day I totally I just need more
time um but I see all your messages and
I really I appreciate everyone's
patience and just prayers and everyone
is so sweet and I really appreciate it
thank you I appreciate it too
we're so similar what do you appreciate
I just appreciate everyone I'm just like
in an appreciative mood are you
appreciative that they're like loving
turdy's family and friends you know I
love family and friends you know it's
like my time to shine yeah but it's so
much harder than doing just like the
regular toast like one being the stories
and the ads girl it's just like there's
no room fraternity to like Express
herself you know yeah and it's not the
same not podcasting with you it's like
we're so natural we're just like you
know we're like Japanese joinery we just
fit
and I love getting to catch up with
everyone and I'm so appreciative for
everyone who came last week I literally
had asked some people like three days
notice and everybody really like moved
stuff around and I was really
appreciative and it was like really
great guests which is always good for
the toast growth reaching new audiences
we love we love
um but there's truly nothing like a
Jackson Cloud original recipe and that's
what we're here to deliver today it's
not delivery it's Jackson Cloud original
recipe yum but you know what I kind of
wish it was delivering afterwards what
are we gonna have for lunch oh we're
back to this I finally get to have this
conversation together not parallel I
know what do you think what do you like
to have for lunch right sweater around
here I really have two options I go for
a warm bowl or a nice wrap a warm bowl I
know and like a new place opened by our
studio with warm bowl options like right
right before you moved so you really
haven't even gotten a chance to explore
the menu no I haven't and I have an
expert here you should open a restaurant
of warm boats cold turkeys warm bowls
turdies warm bowls I'll take you to the
place after like I can show you they do
because I have such a bizarre order but
it's also really simple easy to memorize
yeah and they know me and they love me
they do they do love you yeah one woman
in particular I think like the first
time I ordered from her she was so shook
that I didn't want any sauce I think
this place is like known for their cool
different like aioli dresses come with
sauces yeah and she was like no sauce
and I said no sauce and she's like so no
sauce and I said yeah like no no sauce
and she was like okay no sauce I'm like
yeah no sauce and then we just kind of
bonded after that and now she's my best
friend and that's how you know opposite
to try
Ben is the king of sauces Ben is the
king of sauces actually last night every
once in a while we order wolf and lamb
and if you don't know what that is it is
like probably the nicest of like two
kosher steakhouses in the city it's
extremely expensive because Kosher meat
is expensive and then on top of delivery
it's like oh you're getting a ten dollar
item delivery
so like when you order delivery like
there's always a premium but like when
you're ordering wolf and lamb it's
insane because we order filet mignons
and they're so expensive and then it's
like oh 200 delivery fee every once in a
while we do it and I really wanted it on
Passover but they were closed for
Passover so we just like kind of we just
went we had like a crazy expensive
dinner last night and Ben sits down at
the table with our perfectly cooked
filet mignons and he runs to the fridge
and grabs like four different sauces and
I'm like this is literally like a 60
steak what the [__] do you need your
trash craft sweet baby rays on this
gorgeous teak like it's meant to be not
to be like you know like a foodie but
like that's when people say like you're
going to the best Omakase in the world
like you don't need soy sauce and that's
right I do disagree I do too like Zach
always says the best friend Troy doesn't
need ketchup and that's why your husband
is smarter than you because I completely
agree oh my God no oh I never have
ketchup but we were about to like drag
him no I never have ketchup with a
McDonald's fries no it's so wrong should
we have McDonald's
[Music]
I don't know I'm like so clean these
days it hurts but you know what part of
being clean and I feel like Kourtney
Kardashian is always saying this is like
every now and then like eating the most
vile trash well you know what or we
could get like warm bowls with
McDonald's fries you know what
that's balance and I love that yeah yeah
because I don't want to eat like uh
affiliate fish a mcplant yeah we've
already discussed how it's like kind of
toxic literally but fries are fries
fries are fries I I love should I eat
fries with the strides should I order it
now or like then it won't no or no okay
then we'll sit here like trying not to
eat and then like we'll get and then the
whole studio will smell like McDonald's
it'd be so good
um
what are the good guys talking about
food I know new episode of the good guys
shop today isn't it crazy like the good
guys are like literally becoming the
biggest podcast in the world they had a
mojo on does that affect your
relationship with Ben uh that's a really
good question because two things about
me is like I'm extremely like toxic
competitive self-centered but I also
like really love this supporting life I
I really am so actually no the two
things can be true like I'm actually and
the thing is it's a TNN production so a
win for Ben is a winner for me
everyone's hat but like when he gets
like Tana no when he got like Hillary
deaf and like was in People magazine in
their episode literally got like
millions of downloads like yeah like
that was hard is there a guess that they
could get that would just put you over
the edge that's a good question I mean
of course like Taylor Swift but that's
not happening trust and believe
um but like someone attainable that they
could get yeah that would like kill me
that's a good question who am I like
obsessed with
like Casey Musgraves Luke Combs but like
they would sooner come on toast like
that's not yeah that's unattainable for
them yeah
like a Kardashians they're still from
Friends
that wouldn't kill me honestly some of
the friends characters and this is
actually something I've been wanting to
talk about have been acting so wild on
social media lately
um there must be like an agency I'll
tell you in a second there must be like
a marketing agency that not a lot of
people know about and like new
celebrities have been discovering them
and using them because they're all using
the same tactics and it started with
Meghan Trainor
and now the Jonas brothers are in on it
and Courtney Cox is in on it too what do
they do make insane tick tocks really
high quality like high production value
but like very on Trend getting other
tick tockers other celebrities to the
point where it's so inauthentic but it
performs so well it's so viral and it's
having like major impact on these
people's careers music-wise or just like
celebrity-wise I find it so weird and
annoying like Courtney and Cox has like
recently started to do that she's like
partnering up with all these tick
talkers and like it's just annoying like
I don't like it I'm sorry yeah it's like
ruining Tick Tock I'm sorry it's ruining
Tick Tock so you know what but you're
I'm with I'm with the government viral
last night I did
it was good stuff dude you go viral I
like checked after like 30 minutes after
you posted it but I haven't checked
today I did I did go viral I'm posted a
tick tock and a real that is millions
and hundreds of thousands and you kind
of like went viral within the swifties
with that Tick Tock of like you talking
about and I did go viral because typing
like a viral week for me did you see I
dm'd you a video like a Swifty account
reposted that video and I came about it
organically see that's been like an
interesting thing is I've been making
kind of like Niche content like I made
this Tick Tock um that went viral about
Ben playing golf and it got like ripped
off and put on all these golf pages and
like do not read the comments they are
they're hysterical they call me so toxic
they're like he needs to leave his [__]
ass toxic wife like first of all it was
a joke no and it's like there in the
comments they think either you're having
an affair with Elliot or Ben is having
an affair with Elliot and it's like
there's kind of like these conspiracy
theories in the golf Community about me
and Ben but that's what happens and then
I made like Niche Swifty content like it
gets put on this 50 pages so um yeah
I've kind of like I'm three for three
that's this is the price of going viral
now are you going viral on The Love is
Blind pages I am it's very exciting Ben
is actually Ben's idea like creatively
and he was so like annoyed that like he
didn't think of it himself well he did
he was like but you should do it yeah
and this is kind of the partnership
creatively that we have right that's
like you supporting good guys right he
supports my work dancing but like we
were so panicked that the stream would
start even though like it wasn't we were
rushing Russia most
painful just useless hour of Life yeah
at first it was like fun and exciting
because it was like 8 15 and I was
texting you like is it just me is it you
and the thrill kind of wore off
extremely quickly yeah and I ended up
feeling annoyed
yeah I started a book and then I didn't
feel bad about waiting because it's like
okay that's a perfect thing to do while
you're waiting but then we both gave up
and went towards succession by the time
I logged into HBO Max
the stream was up and then the stream
started for us on Netflix but most
people couldn't watch it and now they've
said it will be up today by 12 p.m
Pacific time so three o'clock like most
people still haven't seen it wow if only
there was something to see we watched it
we'll recap it and just so you know like
if you weren't able to catch it like
godspeed it'd be okay but I have
thoughts also our chat was so funny last
night we read so much we never do that
we never like lie we're always watching
[__] at different times and we like we
save it for the toast but I'm actually
glad we have that chat so in case
there's anything I need to remember
about how I felt yes scroll so maybe we
should dive in because like now we're
talking about we can't stop yeah talking
about it I can't stop
and we won't stop we need to get all of
our singing yeah there was actually not
a lot of singing last week like with the
guest co-host maybe because like I felt
embarrassed do they sing are they
singers Remy sings and snatchler loves a
good snatcher song but I don't know it
wasn't the vibe yeah I guess girlies
aren't as like musical no they're not
just weird thing about us yeah it's just
kind of what makes us we're the musical
podcast but it's not like a thing that
other podcasts do like they don't just
like break out into song and that's kind
of why we're so successful no no and
that we love that about us but that's
like not a normal thing is what I'm
realizing but
but why you know when you were born with
your friends
depends on the friend truly depends on
the friend yeah like my friend Abe is
very musical so yes
maybe it's just like a family thing
maybe well that's what I learned with my
episode with Paige disorbo like birthday
buddies is a family thing she's like
that's not a thing oh so like when I
said we were she and I were birthday
buddies I had said it on the toast too
and it turns out like her we don't have
the same birthday it's November 4th yeah
she's just like someone who's constantly
like celebrated all week on Instagram
and there was confusion yeah yeah but I
brought it up and she's like I've never
heard the term birthday buddy I'm like
wait what did you go to school no I'm
like that was a school thing literally
my childhood yeah you had to like do a
project on your birthday buddy you could
choose any of them maybe it was just our
Niche like Jewish Day School curriculum
I think it should be part of you know
the core yeah the universal curriculum
of Life who's your birthday buddy pick
any of them and do a report yeah how do
you think I know so much about Jessica
Simpson how do you think I know so much
about Sally Field The Flying Nun Jackie
I brought it to Sally Field you have to
watch episode with Paige I know you were
busy but like we literally had this
conversation I literally can't wait I
said you have the same like birthday
week and now maybe if it was today I
would have done my paper on Lamar Oda is
he another birthday buddy of yours kind
of a blessed day a blessed day oh happy
day yeah a couple of scorpios
um
Theo's birthday is coming up and like I
must jump off a bridge yeah I did the
math shut the [__] up okay
okay should we get all the like the shy
guys together maybe get butter Olive
like the whole crew yes you know if I
did ever throw the old birthday like I
would ask the dog walkers I don't know
like Butters I don't know their parents
but I would like ask I would print out
invitations and be like can you pass
these out to the crew leave them under
the door yeah
yeah but I'm not having a birthday party
I don't need all the smelly dogs in my
house no but like what would Theo want
to do like on his best day where did he
like to go to the beach
he would like to go to that walking path
oh my God that's our place me and him
yeah that was before I got Bruno we have
vacationed um at this house many times
that nearby has like this kind of a star
like a nature path it's not even because
it's not a path it's literally acres and
you just walk and walk and there's
Bridges less than two miles but it feels
oh my God it is not Shaggy one time
trying to make us walk the whole thing I
wanted to die I tried to cut through the
field and like literally ended up made
it works by yourself I made it worse
it's not two miles it's 20 years I used
to run it every day like
pick me yeah okay but that's where Theo
would want to spend his birthday it's
such a beautiful like maybe we go maybe
we go let's see what the weather is
we'll see yeah that's the I was like and
it's really beautiful there's like
creeks and bridges and streams and
Fields and trees yeah and benches that I
loved personally yeah that's where Thea
would like to spend his birthday that's
beautiful where would Bruno spend his
birthday in the arms of el nolio yeah on
like the world's largest heating pad
right yes love that for him
has a lot of um interests Hobbies yeah
he really does he's easy to please he
loves Adventure he's a man of many
interests yeah but he'd also be happy in
the bed and then he as long as there's
heat as long as there's heat
Bruno did stay with me for like a couple
days last week it was joyous yeah and
the boys were getting along the boys
were getting along Bruno
um
he actually hasn't stayed with me since
he's been like an independent boy who
doesn't need to sleep in the crate and
who can walk around freely when there's
no one home so this was the first time
where he slept with us and I have to say
it was probably one of the greatest
displeasures of My Life
um you're wrong for that Bruno is the
type of dog who needs to sleep in your
[__] like my God I couldn't get away
from him fast enough and every time I
would like push him or like honestly
kick him like move
right back up my ass I had never slept
so poorly in my entire life it was like
I said one of the greatest displeasures
of my life okay well
Bruno had a great time and that's all
that matters Bruno felt loved Bruno
didn't feel like he wasn't you know with
his mama he didn't feel he was honestly
like who's mama you know like he wasn't
really interested he wasn't like really
like talking about you were actually
probably even thinking about you so it
was totally fine and I did my job as an
empty and a caretaker that he felt loved
and I put his needs before mine letting
him sleep in the bed but I would be
remiss devastated and heartbroken if I
didn't just at least acknowledge how it
was one of the greatest disclosures of
my life okay well I just feel like then
you and Bruno are just like not
compatible sleepers because he and I he
and I are simpatico oh my God I actually
never wanted to like commit animal
cruelty more than I did in my life and I
wanted to kick him in the throat like he
was so annoying I'm sorry I did because
like one thing about me like I'll do
anything for the dogs but like mess with
my sleep like that is just like a No-No
for me
I can't listen to this anymore
especially because like I got my hatch
last week and I was like really wanting
to like test it out
and like Bruno like I was up with Bruno
like I wasn't up with my hatch what do
you think about hachio
I'm obsessed like Ben is obsessed too
I'm loving the nighttime routines and
the morning routines I hadn't been taken
advantage of the nighttime routines yet
I didn't even know it was a thing until
Margaret told me and I kept seeing this
rise button I'm like no this rest button
I'm like what is this for but these like
15 minute like sound baths and lighting
techniques I'm obsessed I've never felt
more rested honestly
welcome yeah I don't feel like I was
like against the hatches this isn't one
of those things it's just something I
turned you on too oh you discovered the
hatch for sure and do you have a code
for the redheads no it's just hatch.co
I'm just like promoting it oh we gotta
get a code because like everyone was
happy you know on some websites where
they're like where'd you hear about this
product say the toes just the redheads
come on oh sorry yeah yeah new episode
dropped two weeks ago it's good stuff
thanks for letting us know well if you
follow me on Instagram you know okay
and our next book is a snitch's choice
and she chose I wonder why a book called
The Magnolia Palace yeah there's kind of
like a really weird thing for her to
choose I don't know why she would have
chosen them the Magnolia Palace but I
think it's historical fiction so I'm not
complaining that's so not counselor I
know that's like the power of el nolio
um okay now it's so much to discuss now
without now now you know what why don't
you
croon's hit it yeah okay hold on
actually wait come here you see it says
it says munch on the soundboard
okay so just wait without further uh did
it did it do here are the fast size
stories that you need to know
gorgeous today's episode is brought to
you by liquid IV liquid IV is the
category winning hydration brand fueling
your well-being and their hydration
multiplier is a one product you're
missing in your daily routine in just
one stick you'll get five essential
vitamins and two times faster hydration
than water alone use it first thing in
the morning before a workout when you
feel a run down after a long night out
and on Long flights I actually took one
this morning because I'm really prone to
migraines when I'm on my period which I
got today so
um dehydration is like a trigger for my
migraines so I took the liquid ID just
to like stay on top of things you know
is that okay with you I just feel like
you could have done the ad without
letting us know I'm so authentic I would
never lie one stick of liquid IV into 16
ounces of water hydrates you two times
faster and more efficiently than water
alone it contains 12 delicious
refreshing flavors that keep your
hydration routine exciting and inside
the pack there are five essential
vitamins B3 B5 B6 B 12 and vitamin C it
has three times the electrolytes of a
traditional sports drink it's made with
premium ingredients it's non-GMO free
from gluten dairy and soy and whatever
like a trigger for dehydration is for
you or like it's hot out you're hungover
whatever the reason is it's important to
stay on top of your hydration and liquid
IV is just like saving you time like why
drink one bottle of water without liquid
IV when you could just drink one bottle
of water with liquid IV and save
yourself having to drink or otherwise
multiply yeah multiply your hydration
that's a good slogan for them I'll tell
them they should get Ed Sheeran to be
the face it could be yes
grab your liquid IV in bulk nationwide
at Costco or you can get 20 off when you
go to liquid iv.com and use code toast
at checkout that's 20 off anything you
order when you shop better hydration
today using promo code toast at liquid
ivy.com today's episode is also brought
to you by ZipRecruiter whether you're
starting a new business growing one if
you want to be if you want to be in it
to be successful you need the most
talented people on your team and that's
why Jackie use ZipRecruiter to find me
the most talented podcaster she's known
that's how we met that's how we met on
ZipRecruiter it's kind of like a Modern
Love Story right now you can try
ZipRecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com toast if you've been
wanting to start a business or you've
been just kind of like having a hard
time finding people to get your business
off the ground try ZipRecruiter here's
why you should let ZipRecruiter hire for
your business there are powerful
matching technology finds highly highly
qualified candidates for a wide range of
roles got your eye on one or two people
who'd be perfect for your job well
ZipRecruiter lets you send them a
personal invitation so they're more
likely to apply ZipRecruiter also offers
attention grabbing labels to speak that
speak to your job flexibility so if
you're offering remote or training
provided urgent you can add those labels
to really help your job stand out let
ZipRecruiter fill all your roles with
the right candidates four out of five
employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
see for yourself go to this exclusive
address ZipRecruiter
dot com slash toast if you want to try
ZipRecruiter for free that's
ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t zip z i p recruiter
r-e-c-r-u-i-t-e-r.com slash toast
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
can't guarantee that you'll find your
turdy Lou but you will find a great
co-worker I actually I can guarantee
that you'll find your turdy Lou like I
can you can yeah you feel strongly about
that sorry I just needed a snack on hand
for what because they get hungry like
but you're gonna eat on the podcast if I
can get really have you learned nothing
let's take a break you'll be hungry
we'll take a break no like next Advent I
could just push my make out wow okay
like comes to New York and like forgets
everything she knows no because I was
just thinking about like how hungry I am
that's fine we haven't even gotten to
the first story yeah and I just feel
like I gotta pass oh I guess pregnancy
pass I feel like we are um like
recording later this is actually like
we're recording when we would eat
because you were like busy this morning
so when we would eat lunch we have
missed a meals sort of and that's just
like not something that's unacceptable
acceptable like you have to have a lot
of small meals yeah like I won't you
won't even know I'm eating if I decide
to yeah you'll get like daggers for me
but go for it wow judgy yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah like one thing about me is
like I put the av-i-t of this show Above
All Else and like you kind of wanting to
eat and like mess with the audio like
that's actually a personal attack
okay but do as you please do what's best
for you thank you our first story
Netflix is apologizing for the 75 minute
love is blind Season 4 Reunion delay we
are incredibly sorry they say so love is
blind reunion was supposed to air live
last night nobody needed it to be live
nobody asked for it live but I I'm
assuming Netflix is trying to get into
live content right
thing but a live reunion is not
something anybody needs and we'll get
into the reasons why I agree later on so
8 P.M we all sit down to watch this show
does not come on for 75 minutes now
we're all on Twitter Netflix is posting
some jokes right even got like so
desperate as to post a picture of Irena
being like will be worth the wait so at
805 they said love is blind we will be
late we're on at 8 15. and you know what
I was okay with that it actually worked
better for my schedule no and like I
understand this is like a big live event
whatever I'm you know I work in Tech so
I understand these things happen and
then at 8 15 nothing happened in for an
hour and they didn't say anything so
everyone's wondering and it's like that
to me is unacceptable to give no sort of
Vanessa Lachey went live and just said
the [__] is follow me Vanessa Michelle
I'm not but then I saw it you know
through the the the for you page yes
through you know the internet did its
thing and she said they're sitting there
they're not speaking they're waiting you
haven't missed anything we broke the
internet uh
we're still here so are you trying to
tell me that more people were trying to
watch The Love is Blind reunion than
we're trying to watch the Chris Rock
special I don't know I personally can't
believe that I know and I just feel like
maybe they had better systems in place
for Chris Rock because that would have
been so unacceptable like right like
who's really the most pissed from Love
is Blind just like the fans and the cast
members like what are they gonna do
their time is over but if that had
happened to Chris Rock like
yeah it would have been really bad for
everyone and he would have been so
pissed so I'm not saying like they don't
they they allowed this to happen but
like that was not an option so then I
guess at like 9 15 they just started to
film and they were like we didn't really
need to get this filmed and then we'll
put it on Netflix at some point but then
for some people they were able to watch
what they were filming live and that
included us so I think they started
filming and they're like we'll work on
getting it up as we're filming and maybe
like 15 minutes into their filming you
could start watching it and all you had
to do was rewind right which is what we
did which is what we did and it maybe I
don't know if it was because we had
waited so long and there was so much
hype that like only you know you're set
up to fail with that much like
excitement and hype after all this but I
found the reunion to be
positively Dreadful
um I guess it just really highlighted
because it wasn't edited to make things
like quick and concise it really it
really highlighted how Beyond
average and mundane these people are
like when you think about live reunions
which my only point of reference is like
the Real Housewives of Miami these are
like professional
reality stars well no even still it was
their first season and it obviously
didn't go well because they never did
something like that again but it was
kind of amazing like it was chaos yeah
but
there are a lot of things where a live
format is great yes people just like
talking about their feelings that needs
to be edited and especially because I
found a group of people who are so long
[__] winded Marshall Zach Paul and
also it's like they're there to talk
about their feelings which always just
takes longer and it's more bushes to
beat around right and like we like kind
of like don't care you know no but when
they first
cut to like I think was Marshall that
like they were catching up with everyone
and they said hi to Marshall and his
answer was too long and I was like this
is why we edit yeah they actually really
it was so obvious how badly they needed
editors because everyone was so
long-winded but I will say on the other
hand there were a lot of people who
without a splice of editing came off
really well yeah and we're really
impressed if I thought Chelsea was so
well spoken and impressive she didn't
stutter she did not like every sentence
meant something of course there were
there was the like crew that was abound
and then there were some of the feelings
people who were talking in circles but I
also felt like it gave a lot of people
the opportunity to shine yeah and if you
can do well live like that like that's
really impressive that's very fair
um I felt like Chelsea and Kwame as a
couple probably came out on top yes they
just they were so in sync with each
other everything that they were saying
was exactly you know I felt very good
about them yeah and I was the type of
person who was completely shocked that
they said yes like I was confused that
Kwame was interested in Chelsea because
the whole time he seemed like he
literally would rather be anywhere else
than by her side and I guess it's what
the feel like the feelings of a lot of
the fans were and they addressed that
head-on and he was just like you
literally saw a drop in the bucket of
what our relationship was and you know
what there's proof in the pudding they
are still married and they seemed really
happy they say that and I'm like
so what we saw like in those moments
okay they're not 100 of the moments that
you had but like we saw them yeah and
this was the first time where I felt
like oh I was Bamboozled and
that is not we did not see an accurate
representation of their relationship I
also didn't really understand why all
this effort was clearly put into the
reunion live they had a live studio
audience they did like a bunch of stuff
and why they chose to have Jackie and
Josh participate via Zoom the day before
I feel like that love triangle was
probably one of the biggest dramas of
the Season maybe they didn't want to
come
but they don't really have a choice you
know it's like Bravo you know you come
really they made it seem to Irina like
she had a choice and she chose to come
and they were it was not a good showing
for Irina like I don't know I am you
know me my voice was so trembly and like
she made no good points she just like
apologized some good points I if
anything it was good for because I
actually felt bad for her because she
like was clearly so nervous she also
looked amazing she did which is always
great it counts for something but I felt
like as best as she could try to explain
herself without being like listen I did
those things and I'm sorry for them yeah
um there were some explanations in there
that I understood me too actually and
maybe because he was just pissing me off
I found Zach to be like holds a little
bit more weight as a villain than he was
he was a victim but he was also giving
villain energy and I saw it during the
show and I think like the way everyone
was coming for Irina and then like he
just like kept going and he just showed
his you know he showed under the hood of
of his mind like when he came out and
like really thought he did something and
he was like I feel like you came on this
show to be famous which is like okay it
doesn't ever run I don't feel that I
mean one yes to some degree if you're
going on reality TV like you're
comfortable with the idea of being known
but if she really wanted to be famous
she would have made their relationship
seem like something wasn't she wouldn't
have asked to go home before Mexico that
context was really important she
wouldn't have ended the relationship as
prematurely as she did because she
kicked herself off the show like if if
Fame was really that motivating for her
she would have hit her feelings made it
to the Altar and said no 100 I
completely agree and I think the context
her adding that she had actually asked
to go home she knew immediately when she
saw him it wasn't the right fit
um adds a lot of color too and I'm sure
sure like they convinced her you know
don't go home and I'm sure she convinced
herself you know what maybe love can
grow from this I guess I like I loved
him in the pods I didn't get that
feeling when I saw him but people have
started off with worse and ended up
together so I understand wanting to go
to Mexico and giving it a shot
I don't think I would have behaved in
the way that she did but like she was
clearly like very awkward very
uncomfortable she was 25 at the time and
doesn't know how to like say these hard
things that she's thinking and feeling
so she just like becomes defensive shuts
down and rude yeah but I just find it
funny so how he literally was like you
know you came on the show to be famous
in the audience the audience was giving
Jerry Springer
shut up
um and he's like you know and if you
really want to see the receipts I'm not
going to bring receipts but if you want
to see them go to my Instagram which I
did by the way and there was probably
like 10 slides of like Notes app story
and I'm sorry I could not read it it was
so long and there were so many typos I
read it oh what was the thesis was it
was a really nice story about like the
power of forgiveness and giving Grace
because he gave that to his mother
um and she had been like very
disappointing over like during his
childhood and like in and out of I saw
she struggled with addiction right but
the moral of the story was that at one
point he just decided like I'm I forgive
you and and she got
sober and was able to be there for him
and they had a few really good years and
moments together that they wouldn't have
had if he hadn't given that Grace and
forgiveness so give Grace and give
forgiveness that was that got a receipt
okay that's not a receipt and he really
was not giving like Grace or forgiveness
energy
um and he doesn't have to and he doesn't
have to said that instead of being like
go check my Instagram he could have been
like
told the story Grace and give well no no
no no like the story would have been the
whole reunion but he could have and and
he could have walked the walk in that
with Irina like yeah what Irina did was
not nice but like
you could it's been a year you're
happily married right she's obviously
come out uh on the bad side of things
you could have given Grace and gay
forgiveness I just want to say like I
went to everyone's Instagrams last night
just to like see what people have been
posting and to be honest based on the
content if there was anyone who just
based on their content who I thought
came on the show to get famous it would
be Zach so I just felt like he was being
really hypocritical and like kind of
loved that he was the victim and he was
a victim like she was wrong but he
leaned into the victim mentality so hard
and whenever people lean into it too
hard like they push a little too far I
start to turn and I felt that way a few
times last night with a few different
people for me that was Zach like he was
bothering me it's like so clear he won
he's there with his wife like they look
so happy and she like the crowd was like
literally booing her and he just kept
kind of like kicking a person when she
was down and I know he has every right
to because like she was really mean to
him like for sure but he came out on top
he has the wife he had the audience and
I just felt like he was so happy to be
the victim that he weirdly turned
himself into the village that's what
keeps happening yes in every show but I
also felt like Micah was leaning a
little too heavily into being a victim
with Paul you know you were texting me
that and I actually don't agree
because I need to look back at my notes
but
I don't know that she would have said
yes first of all and I I like that she
explained why she needed him to go first
because she needed to know that if he
said yes it was like not because she
said yes and you know what I was so
confused when she did that and then I
was like maybe she didn't want to be
embarrassed but her explanation made
complete sense to me yeah just based on
their everybody relationship is
different and like if she's gonna be
married to him forever she needs to know
it's because you know that it was his
choice and she probably felt like she
wasn't getting doubts but when I watched
it like I didn't feel like she was gonna
say yes I just felt like she didn't want
to be the villain nobody wants to be the
villain but like at the end of the day
like these are your real lives and this
is a real marriage so someone has to say
no if it's not right and then Zach comes
in and says other people have said that
like you were never talking about
getting married and when we did see
their relationship on TV like it was not
a serious relationship okay I just
wanted but also we only saw what we saw
what Zach said was so confusing because
he kept changing what he said and what
he ended was like I spoke to a lot of
other women whose opinion it was was
that you didn't want to marry Paul
that's what he ended up saying which is
the most vague thing so what the [__]
she wasn't even friends with really
anyone except Irina yeah so it's like
what are you talking about and and by
the way it turned out that Irena was the
one who was saying that and they haven't
spoken this is Mexico right so it's like
you really don't know anything I felt
like Zach was again trying to like
defend another victim and he was just
turning himself into the villain like I
didn't at first he said a lot of the
other women said you said you weren't
going to marry Paul and that's like and
then it turns out Irina said in Mexico
she didn't think that they would end up
getting married the [__] does she know
yeah I mean she said that because she
was in love with Paul right but also
then with like they tried to make this
Irene Paul thing a storyline which is
not a storyline on Paul's end whatsoever
like what Irina thinks and feels about
him has nothing to do with him and so
they were trying to get like Paul to
apologize for some flirty Behavior going
on and it's like Micah kind of dug into
that and it's like girl after the
conversation with Kwame like I know she
should just be quiet yeah because that
conversation with Kwame we could like
say they needed clothes no that was
crazy that was just inappropriate drunk
you know touching like what could have
been did I make it and that's normal for
humans but just let's just call it what
it was let's color this Shady yeah no of
course
um I did think like when Zach popped in
to like kind of defend Paul it was
because like Nick and Vanessa were like
non-stop asking him follow-up questions
to like him saying that she wasn't
nurturing well why didn't you say it
well that's not really something you say
it's like it's a it's a trait somebody
naturally has and you want to force them
to become something that they're not but
don't you feel like they kind of like
wouldn't let up yeah and on that point I
disagreed with the consensus that if
you're breaking up with someone over
like a feeling that you have that
they're not this or that I don't think
you owe it to them to communicate that I
agree one you could be completely wrong
that could just be how you see them you
don't see Micah as nurturing but she
might be nurturing like you're not the
end-all be all judged but if you have
that like weird gut feeling about
someone I don't think you need to
explain that to them when you're
breaking up like you should have a
conversation about breakups but I don't
think that's something that needs to be
said to her face and what so she could
act more maternal like he nurturing was
the word well maternal nurturing like
because he didn't see her as a mother
um he didn't get that vibe from her but
he also said like maybe I just didn't
bring that out in her right which is
really [__] Fair he was very
diplomatic because what he said like
could have been taken if if you
interpreted it just a face value as so
[__] rude like I didn't see her
really it is rude it's it's a harsh
thing to say about someone and in a
normal relationship you can think that
and feel it but I don't even think you
should tell someone that if you're
breaking up with them regardless like
you can Harbor some reasons things you
think about these weird things you think
about them without telling them but
they're on a TV show so he had to tell
us right and it was really awkward
awkward and and mean yeah I just I
honestly like for me the loser of the
reunion was Zach like shut up and like
his Instagram is so thirsty like
Property Brothers well like he's
obsessed like I'm telling you it's some
literally hate him and with the singing
yeah somebody came on the show to get
famous and I really don't think it was
Irena I think it was [__] Zach yeah
like just look at his Instagram okay
with like the proselytizing about
forgiveness like I can't well acting
like the least forgiving person on the
planet yeah um now I'll talk about
Jackie Josh and Marshall again so
annoying that we had this like turnt
Zoom interview but they do look really
happy and I didn't realize it's actually
been a full year I'm glad that they
delay it so long so we can have some
results proof and they look really happy
and they're definitely better suited for
one another but getting some um insight
into like what went down was really
interesting and like I don't know
Marshall has just been kind of playing
this like you know damn victim but not
victim like sweet angel like this whole
time and he was with the bad bad Jackie
and I feel like we got a peek you know
beneath the the surface of like what
really went down and it's like clearly
here's what happened but like nobody
wanted to say Vanessa saw her career
flashed in front of her eyes she called
him gay Jackie called him because I was
in text messages it wasn't text messages
that were leaked in a group chat she's
like his dick is really big but like he
never wants to [__] and he's like not
aggressive at all like she wants like a
guy who's gonna throw her around did she
say g-a-y
um I think she used the worst word in
the chat in the chat some words were
blurred out I don't know if she said
exactly gay but I mean you could say gay
Jackie this is what I'm saying Teach I'm
not saying because it's a bad word I'm
saying because did she say did she write
out get it yeah I don't know I have to
go look again she was saying like soft
she was saying beta
she was either alluding to Gay and so
she they were like joking around and she
was like oh you don't want to [__] like
maybe you're gay and he's like well you
have a big jaw maybe you're a man and he
made it very clear to say he didn't use
a derogatory word which I think we all
know is you know the word I'm certainly
not gonna say it
no I'm not gonna a letter T got it
um so I think like she tried to make it
seem like he may be said that and then
he was like I did not say that but I
just think it was a really interesting
insight into like I think what we saw
with Jackie and Marshall is not at all
really how it was I think there was like
another side to Marshall and my god did
I despise him last night he could not
get a straight answer but now still
ashamed would like ask a follow-up he's
like well I'm getting there and said oh
we only have so much time right we're
live
when I was watching the show and
Marshall and Jackie were going down and
it's like I know Marshall that Jackie's
like wronger than Marshall but I like
her more Marshall so I'm team Jackie and
then last night I felt Vindicated
because I feel like she was just like
true to herself she got with Marshall it
wasn't a match they had some words along
the way but it wasn't completely
one-sided no and then she gave Josh a
shot and that was the right fit for her
and I believe her that she didn't cheat
and the thing about him wanting to
propose to someone else and here's
what's like people can't even see their
own hypocrisy Marshall's soaps that
cause even if it wasn't cheating even if
the next day she went and spoke to Josh
it's like wow you could really just go
and be with him like right after we
break up and it's like
okay so Jackie and Marshall broke up
then that other girl what's her name
Keisha who I don't even she wasn't a
major player Keisha texted him and they
they started to get together because he
was like well what else am I doing sort
of thing and it's like that's the exact
mentality that Jackie had when she went
with Josh like you did the exact same
thing but you can't even see yourself
yes I don't know if it was just everyone
pissing me off or um it was like a
really bad reunion but I just felt like
everyone who had been villainized for a
good reason like I just really saw their
side and I think the people who became
victims were so so who had like who were
the victims of these like villains
actions were so like living for people
on social media like having sympathy for
them that they leaned in so hard to the
point where it's like calm down it's not
that big of a deal yeah that I started
seeing them as the villains that's how I
feel overall and I also feel like each
of the couples that are married are so
strong yeah and they really believe in
them I couldn't even tell you who I
think is the strongest I mean obviously
but everyone was like up on Tiffany and
Brett's level last night yes and the way
exactly they're so simpatico Chelsea and
Kwame like were just one person they
were like a united front yeah he
defended her he supported her and you
love to see that and he really said
everything right right and it didn't
sound like a line scripted yeah I yeah
no he said everything right I want to
apologize to Chelsea I want to apologize
to Chelsea's family like and I want to
apologize to Chelsea and Kwame for like
not for doubting believing yeah we were
doubters
[Music]
um it was a terrible reunion having said
that I think you know uh Nick Lachey
must have watched last season's Reunion
where he quite literally said four words
and this time he got more this one it is
really Vanessa's thing and like Vanessa
is so invested and and I feel like she
she's getting better and she definitely
cares a lot and she keeps up with
everything you know and all the texts
leaked and all the tick tocks she keeps
up with it all which I feel like is the
sign of like it's a she cares
um but it's just there's something about
it that's not working she puts a lot of
herself into it when it's like hosting
you gotta take yourself out a little bit
there was just like too many personal
moments for her yeah but I think they
feel really
personal and close to the show yeah the
video of the bridesmaid and Paul I had
seen it and two some of the other stuff
she was talking about that would like
rumors that Barbara was uh hired actress
I hadn't seen any of that so I was like
wow you're really deep in it most of us
are just like watching the show and
moving on with our lives right but I did
see Paul and the bridesmaid and it made
me chuckle but I didn't think there was
anything there
no I could see
and I could also see it being like get
out of my way thanks I also feel like
Paul just based on his energy last night
like deeply regretted participating in
this experiment like he kind of just
came out with no wife some people like
really like did not like him they
thought he was a villain in the
relationship because he was the one who
said no
um he like had to answer for all these
personal things last night I just feel
like he was like hating every minute of
it yeah but I don't think he's bad like
I don't think he does that I think he
like went through the process I think he
went into it open eye open-hearted
open-minded went through the entire
thing and came to the conclusion of no
yeah meanwhile I thought it was so
[__] weird when Marshall said like he
wanted to get to the altar with Jackie
like just to that's thirsty yeah like
that's what people do that's what they
were accusing Irena of right like that
was so weird to me it's like you guys
literally hate each other why do you
still want to stand in the altar to have
that chance to make that decision in
that moment like there's no decision
right he's like I was robbed of that
there's no decision to make it's a big
fat no no for me like I like hate
Marshall yeah Marshall and Zach like
hate you because they both were like
living for being the victims yeah I know
you really hate Zach
desperately
but I'm happy for him and Bliss like
they actually looked really happy and
like Tia her dad came around and hear
that kwame's mom came around it to me
it's not a red flag when someone's
parent is like so doubtful it's like
this person raised you gave up
everything for you sacrificed everything
for you and you're gonna do something so
crazy and you know what for Kwame and
for Bliss it worked out the way my
favorite character on this season was
bliss's Dad I know because he was just
speaking facts and I also felt like when
he met Zach he went into it semi-open
minded as much as you could be given the
weirdness of the situation and Zach was
a freak yup Zach was a freak he said do
you fish no do you golf no okay so we
don't have much in common and then Zach
starts talking about the penal code
right like and he's just like flexing
like something that nobody cares this
[__] about and it's like shut up yeah no
it was a bad show I think it was more so
her it wasn't her dad doubting the
process it was just like this is who you
chose it's a fair question but there's
obviously a lot more to Zach and I think
bliss's father has seen that now
and I'm happy for them but I didn't find
Fault in in his reaction me neither and
then Felton kwame's mom like not
participating in the charade
like it sucks now that they've been
married for a year and seemed to have a
good marriage like she wasn't at their
wedding but like it's okay it's okay
because it was like televised and
television fake budding yeah but I did
think it was interesting that Paul and
Micah um dated briefly after the show
yeah because that's a that's all a thing
it's like maybe we're not ready to get
married but I do love you and yeah why
do we have to stop like Raven and SK
from last season but like then he
cheated on her so oh but it then it
didn't work out of natural causes yeah I
feel like the show is really good but
like I need them to like change a few
things like I need them to cut the
episodes down like I need them there's
no reason this needed to be 14 episodes
I feel like every episode we saw the
same people having the same
conversations but like with different
people you know yeah it was just
regurgitating the same I'm not sure and
they give us all that crap but then
there was a conversation between Chelsea
and Micah and it seems juicy and like
why isn't that in the show we saw so
many filler conversations but that one
which is actually substantial because
they never got to finish their
conversation in Mexico we don't see also
it's not there that like Irina dm'd
Bliss saying you dodged a bullet and got
so much heat for it but the Jackie said
it literally said the same thing they
saw Zach and everyone was like oh he's a
freak uh Bliss dodged a bullet right but
only Irena got slack for that yeah
and in my opinion
Irene and dodge a bullet so yeah so
that's love and spline season four yeah
it was a fun ride it was a fun ride it
was fun to be a part of it it was
I mean I'll do it again yeah me too I
didn't do it last season it wasn't a
great season I mean the thing is when I
was on the Netflix page and I was like
scrolling through the first season I
forgot first season was so good like I
know we think about Lauren and Cameron
and they're amazing but like all those
other freaky ass couples Jessica Mark
that girl Stacy who was like the
wellness coach like she was like a freak
like there was so much good stuff yeah
it will like it will never be as good as
it was that first season yeah who how
many couples got married in season three
can you look it up I I honestly have no
idea it was um
no Nick and Danielle no was that a
difference oh okay that wasn't Jared
but there was there's none from season
two because they both got divorced right
two marriages in season three what were
their names and no are they still
together what's the success rate right
now because it's 50 before season with
season one and two yeah
it's honestly like
it's so confusing I cannot remember
anyone's names like after the season is
done airing like I'm done with the show
yeah you know yeah and the people are so
out of my mind forever except Lauren and
Cameron Hamilton like live on forever in
my brain and Jessica Mark and and Amber
Barnett Amber Barnett yes
oh Alexa and Brennan yes from last
season Israeli Queen they're married
still she married like a farmer from the
middle of nowhere and they were so
different but like fell in love
instantly they were like the Brett and
Tiffany of last season great anyone else
married from last season
Nancy bartist okay so we're back to 50
50 odds but got they they're done so no
we're 50 50 odds in the franchise before
season four
right no I don't know like I don't like
with the math I honestly yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
are you ready for our next story if it's
the next story that's brought to you by
Legacy box parshans oh it is all right
who has a VCR anyone
a film projector anyone anyone Bueller
Legacy box allows you to visit your
memories without those Antiquated
machines as easy as one two three so if
you don't have a legacy box you haven't
purchased one yet but you have tons of
like family heirlooms VCRs memories
cassettes locked up in a box somewhere
in your basement get to step in you can
load Legacy box with your old tapes film
and pictures and set and they'll send it
back to you on a thumb drive on the
cloud ready to watch and and easy to
share it is so simple it's like magic so
legacybox is a service that is literally
saving families so much time energy and
money on preserving their old memories
how it works is you'll send in your
legacy box filled with the old tapes
whether that's VHS camcorder Picture
film they're professionally their
professional team will digitize
everything by hand right here in the USA
and you'll get it back on a thumb drive
or the cloud along with your Originals
it's so simple it's like magic we did it
it was the best and then we all like
when it came back plugged it in it was
so easy and watched these old home
videos of us growing up like listening
to The Spice Girl girls like it was so
cute memories that really we would have
forgotten about if we weren't able to
preserve it and we had tried many years
before to like convert the VHS do it
ourselves and it was impossible and like
we borderline ruin some of the videos so
just let the professionals at Legacy box
handle it of course we have a code for a
limited time you can get started
preserving your past and save 50 off
when you go to legacybox.com toast
and share and revisit those special
memories from your past it's
legacybox.com
t-o-a-s-t legacybox.com toast that's a
great thing to do as a gift or if you
just want to do something nice for your
family you'll like ultimately become
like the favorite daughter granddaughter
stepchild whatever
um Auntie it's kind of like a good way
to get in the good races of everyone in
the family
and that's where you are right yeah
constantly because you did it for us I
did are you ready for our next story
which is a little Coachella recap yes
Coachella 2023 weekend one was underway
in Palm Springs California this weekend
and we've got some celebrity
spotting yes it was a lot of celebrities
in attendance yeah and we'll talk about
Coachella in general if there are things
to share but Kendall and Bad Bunny got
close at Coachella 2023 he um was a
performer was a performer they were
spotted like at the festival grounds
walking looking at each other looking
close and and semi-intimate no I mean
like they're dating like and then also
there was like that video of him on golf
cart where he's sitting next to a girl
sitting next to someone whose hair is
blowing onto him and there's a voice in
the background and sounds like our girl
and it looks totally like her chocolate
brown hair and
yeah no but also people are acting like
this is some sort of confirmation it's
already been confirmed that picture of
them on the horse from like last week
like they're dating yeah I think a lot
of people are in denial because they
don't like it people really are
sometimes some couples will like get
together and it's like where they are
spotted together and we're like they're
together yeah and these two show up
literally every day doing something more
you know normal and intimate than ever
before and it's still in the air I just
want to say I know nobody's here for it
I'm so here for it like the headline is
Kendall and Bad Bunny get close at
Coachella as romance rumors heat up no
no as their romance is confirmed no as
their romance is heating up and getting
more serious by the passing day do I
think this is like one true love like
always and forever no but I think this
is a really great thing for both of them
yeah
you know he's really breaking into the
American Market who's more American than
the Kardashians she you know the whole
family needs a boost and he's so well
liked I love this love I agree it looks
like they had a great weekend
um what's bad Kendall's friends like a
lot of them were at Coachella and Justin
were there Justine Kylie was there
without Timothy chalamet everything
really dating I don't know we reported
it last week like her car was spotted
outside his house even though like the
only way they would know that that's
literally her car is like if you know
Christiano told them like it's giving
very much like PR but um it seems like
there is like a lot of proof that they
are seeing each other and I just like I
cannot imagine because to me like Kylie
looks so mature for her age and he looks
so immature for his age it almost looks
predatory the relationship like he looks
14 and she looks 30. yeah it makes me
and she's like a mom like it makes no
sense she's so mature for her age she's
so crazy to me because for so many girls
and women like he is the one their crush
and like for me I'm I just I personally
like I don't feel that way I don't have
crushes on teenagers so like that's just
maybe why I'm not like other girls yeah
what is his age not even that young he
just looks you know who he looks like he
looks like the guy that in this week's
episode of Vanderpump Rules Katie brings
to bowling night she's like I'm dating
someone 25 and I'm like really are you
sure you're not dating someone 12
because he looks so young he looks like
literally like one of my NYU orientation
like leaders he's 27. no he looks 17.
and he's really skinny he's 5 10.
means nothing to me like these facts you
know to me he's like 411 and he's in the
ninth grade like it's just crazy yeah
so she was there that's one that I'm
just gonna keep disbelieving until like
like how people are doing with Kendall
yeah yeah but I believe Kendall and Mr
Bunny and Mr bad yeah another couple
celebrity spotting Shawn Mendes and
Camila Cabello we're pdaing at Coachella
they are not back together according to
sources but that they remain friends
with a lot of love and history between
them they aren't dated and dating again
but they are smooching all over the
festival yeah okay so maybe they're not
dating again but like they're definitely
heating things back up they went to
Coachella together that's like a planned
thing I saw videos and pictures tick
tocks they were like extremely Like
Loving he was like standing behind like
they're like or maybe they're not
boyfriend and girlfriend like they're on
their way I don't know this to me seems
actually really normal like this is what
people do they they oh you're at the
same place the party is like your ex
like oh maybe well they won't they it's
just unfortunate that we are all seeing
it I don't think they'll get back
together because I think whatever reason
they broke up for was obviously serious
enough because they were in a serious
relationship but like if they're both
single and they are on good terms like
why not hook up this is just the weird
thing about Coachella it's like
celebrities kind of forget who they are
and they just like stand in crowds of
massive people which they would never do
and make out like it's just they all act
so normal yeah like Kendall and Bad
Bunny we have another story about
Leonardo DiCaprio it's like you kind of
the coachella's like kind of this like
like
lawlessness where the rules go out the
window but they don't because everyone's
filming everything right and it's not a
safe place no it's not but they act like
it is yeah
I would be here for them getting back
together but I also feel bad for Sabrina
I know even though like Sabrina and
Shawn Mendes like he told us very curtly
uh we're like never a thing are never
going to be a thing and he never wishes
for them to be a thing so my heart hurts
for her as well you know I think she's
doing just fine it hurts more for me
knowing like Sabrina and and Sean are
actually like not together even though
we know they weren't but this works for
my heart yeah I don't mind these two I
know a lot of people dislike them I
think people think they're like a
mismatch but I don't mind them at all
and honestly like when they broke up I
was like okay single Shawn Mendes era
here for it but he gave us a whole bunch
of nothing and the one thing he gave us
he took away in that interview no I'm
not dating Sabrina I hear so his single
era like gives no energy and so you know
what you might as well get back with the
girl who like you've loved for for five
years yeah I'm watching a video of
Camilla like leaving the festivals
walking around with her friends and then
she gets in Sean's car yeah like they're
together yeah I don't hate this
me neither
are you ready for our next celebrity
spotting at Coachella Leo Nardo Leonardo
I love Leonardo he was so good in that
movie about the boat Leonardo DiCaprio
who was spotted with Bradley Cooper's ex
Irina shake at Coachella and the only
reason this is shocking is because she's
37. like him being spotted out with a
model okay whatever like who cares
um a model who's a mother and is 37 I
can't believe it it must be a mystery
appropriate it must be but isn't he not
friends with Bradley
I don't know you would think they would
be but now they're just like the same
person but that doesn't mean they're
friends
yeah but also this looks like the sort
of spotting where it's like they were
standing next to each other right and
there's only like so many cool pockets
of a party that like the cool actually
cool people can like stand in like it
could be a real nothing Burger except
I don't buy it
I am like at a place in my life where
like I genuinely don't care who Leonardo
DiCaprio is dating like to me he gave us
Cami Marone and I'm so grateful did you
watch Daisy Jones no oh she was just
Sensational like she was so and I feel
like you know I love that that he did
that for us because now you know she's a
star and that's what she deserves but
like beyond that like I don't care you
know it's like to me I don't really know
the difference between Irena Shake Gigi
Hadid like all these girls he's been
with like they're just the same to me
yeah
it's not like do something different
like date someone ugly you know
like I just if he could do something to
surprise me like maybe then I'd start
caring but it's just it's regurgitated
it's the same thing you know it sounds
so crazy that he's going to Coachella
like and it makes me sad it's giving
like Kyle Cook energy like you're too
old for this party literally how old is
Leo that's good 47.50
he's something like that how old is he
48 no
Bradley's 48 that's a good 48. Leo's 48.
that's insane like I do feel like at
some point you know I'm all for ages
just a number but like the party is over
you know yeah oh no or like this party's
over for you go to a different party
yeah even Vanessa Hudgins wasn't at
Coachella I didn't [__] to work Queen
booked and busy but she's the queen of
Coach Heller but I did feel like this
year in particular there was a lot I was
like shocked by how many celebrities
were at Coachella oh really yeah
Haley and Justin Kendall like I don't
know I just felt like it was more than
usual like a-listers
it got so big and like it was just so
pervasive and everything and then it
kind of got like a little lane for a
second I feel like now it's just like
quieted off and it was cool like people
weren't doing the most the outfits from
like the influencers and the celebrities
were just like cool low-key cool looks
nothing crazy nothing stupid I did want
to talk about though how like I felt
like the landscape of like Brands and
influencers was really interesting this
year because every year passed it's very
much been like the revolve show
um and I think revolve had like a lot to
prove this year after that whole thing
that happened last year with revolve
Festival but I felt like
revolve was like not really part of the
narrative in terms of me just consuming
other people's content it wasn't like
the place to be I felt like guests
really showed up like they had Alex Earl
and they had all these cool I think I'm
stas
see baby like they had a really cool
house with a lot of cool girls and a
guess was like every other there was
like a lot of other brands like doing
the most and everybody stopped at
revolve like almost as like a rite of
passage on the way to the festival but
it didn't feel like it's felt in years
past where it's like the only thing
going on is revolving raw festival and
if you're not there with revolve you're
like irrelevant yeah it felt like there
was a lot of other cool Brands like
doing cooler things yeah where a lot of
people who were just like sent to
Coachella with to promote a certain
brand like the brand didn't activate or
anything there but like I'm taking this
sunscreen with me into Coachella and
then their their whole stay and
everything is just like sponsored by
that brand which is cool too yeah yeah
it just felt like everybody showed up
like they're finally they took a note
out of revolve's book and like everybody
started competing yeah it was cool yeah
it was I I enjoyed following it this
weekend me too they saw some cute
outfits yeah a lot of big pants that's
the trend yeah no and I'm personally
getting ready for Stagecoach and I know
the Vibes are different but the
aesthetic is overall like kind of like
it's deserty it's bandana like there's
some similarities I'm having so much
trouble like are you gonna wear big
pants because that's the trend like I
actually bought a shirt today that was
like I put it on it arrived today and I
was like oh my God you know what I need
big pants but like I'm not a big pants
girl you know it's like it's the desert
who wants wear pants no
no I'm not a big pants girl no but like
I I literally need pants for this shirt
or else I can't wear the shirt you know
there's really you have to show me there
has to be another way there's not what
did people do before big pans I
and like where do you stand in this time
and place in the history if if you
physically can't wear big pants it's
good that's a good question like I don't
know what would happen if I wore big
pants honestly I'm not a big pants girl
no let's just put it that I'll leave it
at the I feel like you have to be taller
yes you get a baseline yeah
Where Do We Go From Here I don't know
we're being left behind we definitely
are in the pants Department a hundred
percent
are you ready for our next story yes
some things around
um Northwest is making headlines because
she joined Katy Perry on stage in Las
Vegas
as her mom Kim watch from the audience
Kim took North and her friends to Katy
Perry's show in Vegas and they were
having the time of their lives and then
Katie invited North on stage to dance
and North invited her friends on stage
yeah there's a lot to unpack from all
the content on kids I didn't watch every
single video but I did I saw most of it
I thought the whole thing was so cute
and sweet and like not relatable because
they like took a plane but like just
like taking you know your daughter and
her friends to a concert you know
there's an element of relatability not
at the level they went but it was cute
and it was still like kind of normal of
Kim and then when Katie brought her on
stage I'm like oh that's cute and then I
watched the footage of Katie on stage
and like Katie was just like doing the
most for North which was so nice but if
I was a patron of this concert like I
paid money I would be like it was a long
time they had her on there they made a
tick tock they all dance and they bought
the friends over it wasn't just like
everyone give it up for doors like it
was like a long Saga it was like several
stories that were all about 60 seconds
and if I was at the concert just to hear
Katy Perry like I would have been
annoyed like it was a lot it made me
wonder if like in every concert she
brings some kids up for like a kid
segment I don't think so
it could be like context is key it could
be in that like in this concert it was
going to be like North and friends
because they were there
um but that was the exact thought I had
when I saw it I was like this is so cool
for north and her friends but it's a lot
but if I was at this concert I'm like
I'm leaving yeah and Katie it was like
so cute and sweet with the girls and
like she's obviously like really
maternal and like we don't really ever
see that side of her because she keeps
her like Mom life private so it was very
cool and and it was sweet but it was
just um it was a really long you know
time for her to be up on that stage yeah
and when when Katie brought North and
she was like do you want to make a tick
tock with me North is like can my
friends come up it was so sweet like
North is a really sweet kid right you
forget she's just like a nine-year-old
girl yeah and I think I said this last
week I was talking to someone one of the
guests about her like I feel like a lot
of us have like this preconceived notion
of North in our head that she's probably
like this Diva monster just because
she's the oldest and I don't know that's
just like how I personally follow Nori's
black book yeah yeah I just perceive her
as like being this spoiled brat and
every time I see her like speak she's so
sweet and soft she's so cute and she's
like can I bring my friends up like it
was so cute and I was shocked I don't
know why yeah that she's just a kid we
have her like in our heads on this
pedestal Larger than Life person 100
nine she's nine but that's pretty cool
uh also Kim had recently taken like
Saint and his friends to all over Europe
to see soccer games like up close and
see all the players they're like big
soccer fans and it's just like
where do you go from there it's down you
know what's like how do you impress them
after that
that's why I think I feel like the kids
would be monsters right that's why but
it seems like they really do appreciate
it yeah and they looked at even the
videos of like saying in the and the
soccer players like they were freaking
out yeah no and how long does that last
for when Katie called oh is that
Northwest North was screaming and then
when she said north do you want to come
on stage it wasn't like she expected
that she was screaming all the girls
were like jumping up it was so cute and
it was really genuine shock yeah but I
would have expected her to be like it's
about time you know yeah or be like no
maybe she'll get to a place where that's
her reaction to these things right or
she goes to a concert and she's like why
aren't I on stage and then we got a lot
of behind the scenes footage after the
show where um Sia came with them and
Paris Hilton too it was kind of like
this random crew it's so fun yeah and
like if you had kids and you in the
collective you and and money like Kim
does like that's what you would do and
like what how can you curate a better
time for your kids no it's so true it
was really sweet but like there was an
element of weirdness to it where I was
like okay get on with the show yeah yeah
yeah
it looked like a good show though yeah
Katie's um residency has been like
pretty successful to the point where
like no one talks about it you know what
I mean yeah it's not like on the level
of Adele where it's like everything she
does is spoken about but it's not a flop
she sells really good tickets and she's
kind of like the perfect candidate for a
residency because she weirdly is like in
this like Legend era like she's not
releasing new music she probably
couldn't if she really wanted to to the
point where it would be like a
successful as her old music but she has
this insane catalog of music yeah I did
see a headline she was talking about
like touring after her residency maybe
it's like a greatest hits tour I
very talented vocalist
yes well we know where she will be
performing next because our next story a
little car Nation news it's correction
day and Katy Perry and Lionel Richie
will lead King Charles Cavalier Spaniels
Carnation concert and here's who else is
performing
so on Friday the BBC announced the
roster of performers gracing the stage
at the coronation concert on Sunday May
7th oh it's coming up I feel like we've
been talking about it oh I mean I didn't
talk about it with anyone last week
because like I just like wasn't in the
mood for Royal news but we could talk
about it now the Prince Harry is going
and Megan is not yeah we'll talk about
it uh at some point in the story I think
um the concert is one day after King
Charles and queen Camilla are crowned at
Westminster Abbey Lionel Richie Katy
Perry and Andrea Bocelli wow highlight
the lineup which also includes the
British pop group take that plus UK
Talent sir Bryn terfel Frio ridings and
Alexis for French
it's not like star-studded is what you'd
say okay yeah but globally I would say
those first three names are really good
really big there's no it's not
embarrassment here yes he's having some
local talent to highlight I mean why not
highlight some of our National Treasures
no it's on the back of Katy Perry Lionel
Richie and Andrea Bocelli for like the
three main Headliners if you will for
not one of them to be British like is a
little bit of a disgrace like the fact
and when you think about like the
biggest stars in the world like so many
of them are British Adele Ellie Goulding
Harry Styles like there are so many so
the fact that none of them are either
available or willing to do it like does
give me pause I can't lie yeah
um but this is not an embarrassing
lineup but when you look really into it
and you notice that none of the three
major people are British like it
definitely is weird
yeah but we already like kind of crossed
that bat like we already have this
conversation like there's big stars
either they really are unavailable we
looked at their tour schedules like
Harry really couldn't even if he wanted
to I think uh
um yeah Adele like could have done it
yeah she didn't want to yeah she didn't
want to and so there's a few like gaping
no but you also have to reconcile the
fact that like it's entirely possible
like I don't really know the landscape
of like British politics but it's
entirely possible it's like when a
certain celebrity doesn't want to
perform for like one president's
inauguration like it's a political thing
yes and they might not be monarchists at
their core right so we've accepted that
yeah that the top tier of British
aristocracy
Talon is either booked and busy or
anti-anti and so now it was really just
a question of who they would get and I I
am feeling very relieved for Charles
that this is not embarrassing these are
three AAA super a yeah Bocelli like I
think it's going to be great I can't
wait to watch yeah I think it's very
interesting that both Katy Perry and
Lionel Richie are doing it together
makes me think they might have the same
agent because like they're both on
American Idol together and now they're
both doing the car Nation together and
they're friends so like it's nice it
adds like a nice little narrative
um and I've just like recently been
loving Lionel Richie I feel like he was
just in the Brook Shields I kind of am
he's so great on American Idol he was
just in the Brooke Shield documentary
where he really came off looking so well
and I don't know if it wasn't the point
of the documentary but she was at this
point where she was talking about how
like so many men in the industry like
took advantage of her and sexualized her
and then it's just Lionel Richie who is
there as like a friend giving
testimonials
um talking about how he's known her
since she was so young and they've
always been really close and it just
made him look even better because all
the men in the in Brooke's story were
like turning out to be villains like her
husband and her whatever so I just love
Lionel and then of course he's Sophia
and Nicole's Father which just adds like
another element she's getting married
like any day the Jews I know she's
converting you weren't here but I talked
about it with Ben he was very excited
because she was like so excited and
proud and a lot of celebrity Jews are
like so quiet about their faith
um
she's kind of like this Timeless in
terms of style like she's really this
like elegant classic Timeless queen and
I think her wedding is going to be I
think it's going to be like up there
we're like Nicola Pelt it's like I think
it's gonna be
gorgeous because like she's obviously
Hollywood royalty she's marrying someone
who's like a business royalty you know I
think it's going to be kind of like a
next level of hair yeah I'm excited I am
excited too are you ready for our fifth
and final story oh my God no no no I'm
not somebody tell page text [__] my
[__] iPad okay sorry you asked me
something I couldn't hear you are you
ready for our fifth and final story
only if it's the fifth and final story
that's brought to you by game time
buying tickets for your favorite events
shouldn't be stressful game time is the
fast and easy way to buy tickets for all
the sports music comedy and theater near
you with killer deals on last minute
tickets and their best price guarantee
you can stop stressing over the tickets
and start getting hyped for the fun
you'll actually have I want to say I've
seen so many people getting last minute
like day of tickets to eras through game
time with like really good seats game
time is the place for last minute ticket
deals forget planning months in advance
because that's never been something I
care to do game time has deals on
tickets right up to the day of the event
they get exclusive Flash Deals on
tickets for football basketball baseball
concerts comedy theater more the game
time guarantee means you'll always get
the best price
the best price if you find tickets in
the same section and row for Less game
time will credit you 110 of the
difference so it's the fastest growing
ticket app in the country for a reason
you'll get images of your seats before
you buy you know exactly what to expect
when you arrive and you can buy tickets
in a matter of seconds two Taps and
you're set the tickets are sent directly
to your phone you'll never have to dig
through your email snag the tickets
without the stress with Game Time
download the game time app create an
account and use code toast for 20 off
your first purchase terms apply again
just create an account and redeem with
code toast for 20 off you just have to
download the app it's game time
g-a-m-e-t-i-m-e create that account and
use code toast you'll get 20 off your
first purchase that's code toast
t-o-a-s-t today's episode is also
brought to you by Squarespace all right
if you work in e-commerce you have a
side hustle you want to work in
e-commerce from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business
so whether you're starting a website for
a podcast you want to start or a blog or
you work in education there's so many
different features on squarespace's
websites that really help you get it all
done and you don't have to be a
professional you do not have to have
like a backware in software engineering
I have made many websites over my time
and I have used Squarespace and I can
tell you your website comes out looking
fabulous and it is so easy so if you're
looking to sell stuff in terms of
e-commerce Squarespace is everything to
sell anything they have the tools you
need to get your business off the ground
including e-commerce templates inventory
management a simple checkout process and
secure payments whatever you sell
Squarespace has merchandising features
to make your products look their best
online they offer traffic overview so
you'll get insights into how your visits
unique visitors and Page views are
trending you can gain insight into the
top traffic sources product device types
browsers operating systems you'll get
like a really really detailed
um over overview of what's working and
what's not working and you know you got
to lean into the data we're constantly
leaning into the data here at the toast
also what I love about Squarespace is
their content ownership so you are
owning all the content that you put on
the Squarespace platform they offer a
one-click data portability so check out
squarespace.com toast for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch use
offer code toast you'll save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
again that's squarespace.com toast for a
free trial and once you're ready to
launch use the offer code toast to save
10 off your first purchase of a website
or a domain thank you Claudia you're
welcome
are you ready for our story now oh you
sound serious I was gonna like I don't
know make a joke oh Squarespace and go
please but only like maybe like having
being like a a small business man Beau
I prefer a big business member from
being honest though
that's why I just moved on yeah it was
good it wasn't a fully formed it's fine
we worked through it our
story raqueline
Terry facility for mental health
counseling people has confirmed she is
treating seeking treatment for her
mental health more than a month after
the news of scandaval broke
um she entered a program in Arizona a
plan that her rep says she's been
considering for some time quote
uh the rep said quote Raquel and her
family decided before the relationship
was discovered that she would enter a
voluntary facility for mental health
counseling she was scheduled to go in
pre-reunion but decided she wanted to
finish her filming commitment Bravo and
production were aware and in support of
her journey towards better mental health
her rep confirms she's not there for
Rehab but rather a program focused on
mental health and trauma therapy
I um I'm literally not surprised by this
I don't I think like any human being who
had to deal with with what Raquel had to
deal with their own actions of course
um would be having a mental health
crisis I wouldn't be surprised if she
was having like a full-blown [__]
mental breakdown but I did also hear she
went to Mirabal like Canyon Ranch well
the statement is a little confusing
because it says that she decided that
she was going before the relationship
was discovered bird so she's going to
mental health facility not because of
everything that's happened with
scandabal because I would agree with you
when we go through this like it is very
traumatizing and traumatizing so they're
saying she's always planned on going
and it's not because of the Fallout but
maybe like she maybe she engaged with
Tom in the way that she did because of
the price of health issues that she has
yeah
it's very PR spin yeah but I don't want
to doubt like what she might have been
going through what's maybe happened to
her I'm kind of like a wait and see sort
of person but so far this seems like you
know the steps that you take in your
road to
a comeback yeah yeah I don't know I
think also just having conversations
last week with Paige and Hannah who are
both reality starts with how to deal
with like their own share of like
backlash which was on a much smaller
scale I felt like when we were talking
about it they both had like a lot of
sympathy or for Raquel like and not in
any way that I'm not team Ariana but
like I do
find myself really feeling for Raquel in
a way that like I I don't have those
feelings for Tom like not even in the
slightest like to me everything that's
happening to Tom is like a direct result
of him just being really like a terrible
human being for 10 years like I don't I
don't know I don't feel sympathetic
towards him I do feel like like maybe
it's because everyone's really coming
for Raquel really hard a lot of the
girls on the cast too like this whole
Rachel thing they're just like really
coming for Raquel more so than they're
coming for Tom and I don't know I just
like feel I'm still like I I don't want
this to be taken out of context because
like I'm very much team Ariana but like
I'm human and like I like feel bad for
Raquel like she obviously [__] up
she's obviously like a person who's
clearly dealing with some sort of Crisis
because she you know finds Tom Sandoval
attractive and that's obviously the
first sign of mental illness
um but I don't know I feel real like I'm
starting like I feel really bad for her
I agree I mean we said this like
throughout scannable as much as like the
tea is hot and and it's a crazy thing
that happened like she's a person right
and a human being is not not meant to
withstand this amount of criticism on
this volume
and it's really like it's her personal
life it's a professional like that she's
been wiped out yeah and it's like
everyone even like the bass suitcases
did you see that thing oh yeah yeah yeah
like they got in on the drama she can't
even leave her house with a purse
without the company of the person we
hate you here's a full suit of suitcases
to Ariana it's like oh my God it's just
a lot like
and I know she had an affair and I know
she's wrong in this and like I get and
two things can be true like I I can
reconcile both and I'm just like I don't
know which it feels like it's crossed a
line honestly yeah it's it's the volume
is is really crazy but and then so I
would understand if she was going away
to take time from all of this and just
like
focus on herself but that's not what
they said like they're saying it's
irregardless of scandival she was going
to a facility no and I had read online
that the facility which they said was in
Arizona is miraval which is not like a
mental health facility it's like a spa
time off is time I agree I agree but
like I do feel like if that's the case
then that statement is like
intentionally misleading and and I think
the statement is intentional misleading
I think a lot of it is um
Spin and PR and as I said like the
things that you do in order to come back
from something but I also think she's
really going through something so it's
not true that mental health counseling
would be good for her image and good for
her mental health right right so true
I just honestly
um
like I'm just eye on it like now I'm at
the point where every everything that's
coming out is like giving me the ick
it's not like yeah yeah stuff against
Tom I'm still yeah yeah but the Raquel
stuff I don't know I just feel like I
know this sounds crazy I just feel like
like she had an affair with time against
her will like I know that sounds crazy I
I feel like she's not a person who can
like really like control her decisions I
know I just I'm seeing it well her
original statement said that she's like
addicted to love and attention and like
maybe she was clearly at a low point in
her life this season and like drinking
and just feeling so lonely and she's
susceptible but she is responsible for
actions but I also think like people can
like do bad things and still be with the
reason you know Irina being mean to Zach
right and okay so you did it right now
what now what we don't have to you know
hang you put your head on a spike I know
I know and it gets to the point where
it's like okay it's a little too much
now yeah and Ariana's living her life
like she's out of Coachella she was
spotted making out with this Hawk I like
good good and I'm not saying that she's
not the victim she 100 is but like I do
think it's gone to like a little bit of
a crazy place
yeah I think so too and I I just think
everything is fluid you know okay so
it's done so it's in it what now yeah
like it doesn't mean and I also
I also take all this stuff like
off the internet off the show do things
in real life do things in Instagram
comments it's like
there's no need for that yeah you know
like we could talk like it's gossip and
it's entertainment and they're on the
phone and it's all fodder and so we're
like a living for yeah but I don't go
comment on markel's Instagram no no no
no you know I don't show up at Tom Tom
no no no no I mean Schwartz and Sandy's
or TomTom or either of them right you
know I just I move on right right and so
I think people like need to have be able
to separate that this isn't your life
yeah
um okay well those are the Fast Five
do you want to talk about succession I
didn't watch succession but I did want
to do like a little content recap okay
all sorts of mediums yeah that's okay
because I did a lot of reading I finally
read that little mini Jessica Simpson oh
yeah she's released like an addendum
which by the way everyone should read
because it's 28 pages and accounts
towards your Goodreads goal and it was
so cute I read it in 30 minutes because
it's 28 pages and it was just like this
I don't know why this was written but it
was fun to go back to her is it
fictional or it's just like a story
about her life it's one more like story
about her life it's not fictional but
it's about like a movie star who was
unnamed but I remember like reading
rumors that it was Mark Wahlberg oh okay
but I need to like now go and
cross-reference everything and she did
give a lot of Clues like I feel like
someone could figure it out yeah yeah I
feel like not enough people cared that's
a thing yeah or they just settled or
maybe I just don't know where to look
right you know because like People
magazine isn't going to be like it's
this person that slanderous because he's
like cheating on someone
um and it was really cute and I love our
girl it was fun to go back into the
world of open book for 30 minutes it's
such a good book and then I read Paris
Hilton's Memoir oh yeah Paris the Memoir
and it was so good and I read it in like
two days and I just like kept wanting to
keep reading it
um it was really well written while also
being so true to Paris I didn't realize
her having like ADHD is such it's like
one of the big themes of the book and
something that like runs through it and
like the way that and she wasn't
diagnosed until she was in her 20s so
like in her childhood it's like she was
constantly acting out constantly seeking
adrenaline they didn't sit still
couldn't focus and so she like found all
these different Avenues to like Channel
her energy which were oftentimes like
the wrong places of course 15 year old
to go to the club but she just love the
lights and the music and like that her
brain is like it's needed that
stimulation and so that was like a
really big theme and I also feel like in
Reading someone's book and this in
particular like I could really
understand her and like why she is
always DJing like and you would think
like someone doesn't want to be in the
clubs forever but like the way that the
music is like it it like speaks to her
brain and it's not something I feel like
oftentimes when we talk about
celebrities we try to like get inside
their head and be like well maybe she's
the type of person and that's why I like
reading celebrity Memoirs because now
like I get it yeah so it was a really
great perspective on Paris it was a lot
about the like uh Provo right EGS
schools that she had went to if I hadn't
seen her documentary
um I would have been like floored by
this book there are a lot more details
in the book than there were in the
documentary but I I could feel you know
what was you had contact because I had
context
um and it was really really good also
it's like a big bombshell or like did
she mention other celebrities oh yeah
tons she talks about Brittany a lot
they're really they're real friends oh
nice um she like talked about the moment
in the car with like Brittany and
Lindsay like how they all wound up
sitting in like in the front seats
together and it was like so not meant to
be iconic yeah like and Lindsay like was
shouldn't have been getting in the car
she didn't fit it was a two-seater
um but how because sometimes she would
like go down a rabbit hole of like
something dark and she'd be like my
brain doesn't want to go here let me
think about something good and she'd
like flip through stories and she'd then
start telling like a random like the
book really operated in the same way
that her brain does a lot of run-on
sentences which she said like that's how
I think and that's how I talk and it
took a second to get used to yeah but
then like whoever she worked with on
writing because I'm sure like she had
helped they really captured her spirit
that's the thing and she's so spirited I
think a lot of celebrity Memoirs and the
best celebrity Memoirs it's everyone
works with a writer that doesn't take
away from the validity of it whether
it's like a Ghostwriter or it's on you
know written with
um but when you can really hear the
person's voice reading it to you that's
in my opinion like a successful
celebrity Memoir that's honestly why I
did not like Mariah Carey's like it was
so sophisticated and dense and this is
how that [__] talks like we've heard
her talk she's hilarious like no it was
very dense it was so not like Mariah was
reading it to me and like Jessica
Simpson I heard in Andy Collins books
it's so Andy like when you can hear
their voice come through I love that yes
agreed Mariah's book was good though
because it was an amazing story yes but
the writing but it kind of is not what
you would it didn't sound like her
um I gave the book five stars met all
Memoir criteria in Celebrity Memoir
criteria from me
um
there was just like interesting factoids
and Nuggets in there you know
but nothing like so crazy crazy that I I
had never heard a lick of but I felt
like I understood her childhood better
because it felt like whenever she talks
about her childhood it's like do they
live in New York or they lived in L.A
how is she friends with Nicole and
Cameron but she they lived at the
Waldorf right and the all the jumping
around is like thoroughly explained and
then and I really and is their
connection to the Hilton Hotel franchise
explained yeah they're her great
grandfather is Conrad Hilton who started
Hilton hotel but they don't own it
um no uh they're not still involved but
that's like not what her dad does right
right he's like a real estate type yeah
but she said like the most I will ever
benefit from the Hilton name considering
Conrad donated most of his fortune to
charity which like was known
um she said the most I benefit from the
name is that I'm now in Hilton
commercials right so now it looks like
she's actually like a founder of the
company because she works every time she
goes on her honeymoon was sponsored by
Hilton and it's very smart of Hilton to
you know capitalize on literally
somebody with the last name but it makes
it confusing yeah but she like talks
about like a lot of the stories behind
the iconic moments like the picture with
Dave La Chapelle and her grandparents
house giving the finger like yes how all
of that came to be and and then you go
and Google the picture and it's like wow
those are right there that's type of
books but like you end up Google
sometimes she'll be like Google this
she was like I love jumping over fences
I've been doing at my grandparents house
since I was little like I'll do it to
get out of any situation she was like
Google Daily Mail 2007 like jumping out
by the way I love that yeah yeah okay I
want to read it you should read it good
beach read yeah maybe like if somebody
could take me to a beach I'll go but
there was like a lot of traumatic
experiences yeah so a trigger warning I
don't want to like give too much away
but um she's just a great wonderful
woman and Powerful good I read too
nothing crazy
um I'm reading one of us is dead
have you heard of it no just like a like
rich women in Atlanta and I guess one of
them is dead I don't know who yet and
I'm still 50 whoa yeah I know
um it's like you know Rich politics
Buckhead it's good I started a new book
last night I think I'm only six percent
in but the first six percent it's giving
luckiest girl alive it's giving Ani uh
what's it uh called it's called the
social climber uh was it about me
um I don't know what happens in the book
but it's like you know a very ambitious
Cut Throat
almost let me know if I should read it I
will but so far I'm like the tone of it
is reminding me of ani and then I read
this book called by Abby Jimenez called
Yours Truly which is the sequel It's
like a really good book that I liked
called part of your world and I'm here
to tell you like please don't read it it
was like really truly horrible great
yeah
and then I read a book that I don't
remember the name I think it must have
been really good you must remember this
I don't know how it ended up on my want
to read but I was like I could go for
you know a nameless Thriller and
for me
and not for me oh I watched the first
three episodes of the final season of
maisel it's pretty good I like I don't
know why I watch it I just like it and
nobody watches it and it's crazy how it
was literally the show with the most
Fanfare of all time like swept every
award show for two years in a row and I
think people literally forget it that
it's still on but it's the final season
and it's pretty good
um and I watch I watch the first five
out of six episodes of Belgravia which
is Julian fellows of Downton Abbey and
it's so good so far but it's only six
episodes and I don't think there's a
second season so like why waste your
time no no like I'm sad yeah but no I'm
glad to have had my time with Belgravia
the second season of Gilded Age no but
it's coming oh okay
um so that's the TV recap that's the
content recap and that's our show
correct that's our show
I feel good I feel like we got it all
out thank you guys so much what we
needed to say it's been said it's been
said and that's really all you can hope
for at the end of a podcast you know and
at the end of uh how long an hour and 30
minutes so the car is about to run out
perfect timing thank you guys so much
for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know everybody through Friday on YouTube
so you're watching this on YouTube
please remember to subscribing give this
video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so Spotify
iTunes republics all the places wherever
you send a podcast review about a
beautiful stunning and what
talented we are hope you guys have an
amazing Monday and we'll see you
tomorrow love Tuesday love you bye hi